[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous leurs du 7-8 journal sur
tv 60,18 bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'information locale tout de
suite les titres de ce lundi 11 décembre
la 31e édition du téléthon se tenait ce
week-end deux journaux de mobilisation
pour faire progresser la lutte contre
les maladies neuromusculaires plusieurs
animations se tenait dans les communes
zibeline oise bilan à suivre en images
et avec notre invité daniel base ans il
est le coordinateur de l'afm téléthon
dans l'est des civils autre mobilisation
solidaire à versailles un collectif
apporte son soutien aux migrants
hébergés dans la ville ils mènent des
actions repas conviviaux distribution de
vêtements chauds pour l'hiver ou encore
services de petit déjeuner dans les
files d'attentes de la préfecture des
yvelines à notre invité est membre de ce
collectif martin miley et puis c'est
signé mort corps va bientôt sur cinéma
multiplex de huit salles ouvrira ses
portes en 2019 dans le village des
loisirs un projet vieux de 14 ans qui va
enfin se concrétiser
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres une
circulation ralentie ce matin sur la
nationale 10 à hauteur de trappes et
vers 8h20 à grave accident de la route
impliquant trois véhicules s'est produit
sur l'ex dans le sens province paris
deux personnes ont été blessées l'une
d'entre elles désincarcéré par les
secours une voie a été fermée pendant
une grande partie de la matinée
compliquant sérieusement le trafic
c'était le marathon solidaire du
week-end le 31e téléthon se déroulait à
vendredi et samedi plusieurs habitants
communes et associations de saint
quentin en yvelines ainsi que du
département étaient mobilisés pour
récolter des fonds en faveur de la lutte
contre les maladies et génétiques
neuromusculaires apnée cyclisme ou
encore course à pied
yvelinois ont été au bout d'eux mêmes le
bilan de cette édition 2010 est avec
mélanie poquet nicolas landry miquel et
demi d'euros et les arrêts ch
trois rendez vous sportif pour la bonne
cause de la natation du cyclisme et des
activités variées ce week end en faveur
du téléthon les yvelinois ont mouillé
les t-shirts à la piscine de saint cyr
l'école le nageur andy cabreira davila a
réalisé une prouesse 24 heures non-stop
de longueur en apnée un record mondial
pour un challenge caritatif oui on a
très très faim d'accomplir mai
j'ai fait pas tout seul c'est un travail
d'équipé et c'est ça qui prime c'est un
travail d'équipé chacun apporté des
choix pour que cette manifestation a vu
le jour aujourd'hui 2134 longueur pour
un peu plus de 53 km en dit peut être
fier sont des fils a réunit des
passionnés mais aussi des curieux
ce qui a permis de récolter plus de 1000
euros je trouve que par son record on
peut y arriver avec de la volonté
la motivation il a fait que quinze
minutes de pause sur les 24 heures c'est
incroyable et il donne de l'espoir aux
malades et il nous accompagne pour ça du
côté des deux roule des filles étaient
aussi sportif six jours de route pour
serge cordon et sa troupe partie de vire
en normandie ils sont arrivés vendredi
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines depuis reims hier oui très
dur les ardennes la boule à neige la
grêle le vent n'a pris beaucoup de
retard mais nous on sait pourquoi on est
sur le vélo c'est l'action pour les
malades donc nous on est une semaine sur
le vélo a quand même pas se plaindre par
rapport à ces gens qui sont malades 24
heures sur 24 chaque année depuis 1991
l'association se mobilise pour soutenir
les myopathes lors de leur parcours ils
ont ainsi rendu visite à des centres et
des familles touchées par la maladie
au terme de ces 1500 km serge et son
équipe ont posé les roues sur la piste
du vélodrome
à montigny le bretonneux la mobilisation
était au rendez vous escalade judo ou
encore course à pied les pompiers des
yvelines se sont relayés pour une course
à pied pendant presque 24 heures
une manière de donner un message rempli
d'espérance les soirs je pense que le
mot c'est l'espoir malgré
le temps la météo des événements
extérieurs on a pu réussir à
récolter une belle somme et surtout à
créer un engouement
c'était sympa les yvelines ont récolté
près de 780 5000 euros un chiffre en
baisse par rapport à l'an dernier mais
c'est encore possible de donner au 36 37
ou sur leur site internet
et pour parler encore de ce bilan du
téléthon sur le territoire daniel basant
bonsoir une bonne fin nous est le
coordinateur de l'afm téléthon sur le
secteur reste des yvelines avec moi
également au plateau martin miley
bonsoir ça va elle fait partie d'un
collectif qui oeuvre pour les migrants à
versailles reste avec nous on voit ça
juste après on va parler d'abord du
téléthon l'a vu dans ce reportage daniel
basant les dons pour cette édition 2010
est dans les yvelines sont en baisse
près de 780 5000 euros récoltés
finalement sans baisse aussi comme au
niveau national
non pas du tout en donnant un pote vidéo
pourtant les chinois je lai sur les
yvelines sur les yvelines je peux dire
que
un lieu où on parle là l'un situation et
je dirais on a été mal informés alors
qu'elle quel premier bilan vous pouvez
tirer on mon ami jours de la fin de ce
chien j'ai eu 16 nouvelles
manifestations et j'en ai des gens qui
sont remontés et qui sent très très 11
vu les estimations qui le donnaient 90
puis sur le terrain on a fait un petit
peu le tour des manifestations on peut
dire qu'une bonne ambiance montini tout
ça avec nos amis les pompiers qui
augmente chaque année un petit peu leur
leur parcours tous les défis de course à
pied 24 heures de course à pied tout à
fait important d'avoir ce soutien des
pompiers tout à fait parce qu'elle est
pompier ben c'est quand même les
premiers partenaires depuis 87 donc et
cette année encore ils y ont été
présents pas mal alors c'est vrai que le
chiffre au niveau national est en baisse
un bon on est encore ressenti sur le
secteur est des yvelines vont peut-être
pas encore des bilans chiffrés mais on
est on est comment par rapport à l'année
dernière par exemple sur le secteur est
dédé moi je dirais qu'on serait en train
voire équivalent voire plus tôt je
dirais plutôt ça avec moins de contrats
d'accord moins de contraintes du 16
nouveaux événements cette année sur
scène ces événements est dans un pays où
il y avait une très grosse manifestation
et qui nous rapporte 4000 euros alors il
y avait un autre événement ce week end
bien sûr c'était là le l'hommage qui a
été rendu à johnny hallyday est ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'il ya eu deux
fois ça s'est ressenti sur la
mobilisation s'est ressenti dans le
milieu d'après-midi oui en effet d'un
milieu d'après midi pendant 2
la marche sur paris donc là en un senti
quand même manque de présence serait à
peu près partout
mais vendredi soir et samedi soir mans
le mans est plein le monde s'en remet
d'une mondialisation sont toujours
mobilisés ce que par exemple des des
hommages qui est des adaptations des
hommages peut-être rendu aussi à
l'occasion du téléthon à johnny hallyday
alors poigny la forêt poignet d'un fort
et un nouveau contraint un concert
c'est un pas et événements c'était prévu
déjà en amant mais bon un concert avec
un idole johnny hallyday d'accord et qui
nous a remporté la somme de 1400 15
euros donc pareil une très belle somme
pour une petite commune comme ça ou
parler de 1400 euros récoltés à peu près
1000 euros aussi par ce défi on dit
cabréra davila qu'on a vu dans ce
reportage
une performance incroyable 24 heures de
nage en apnée bon il a fait il a fait
plusieurs pauses mais voilà 24 heures en
apnée dynamique qui incarne record
mondial
oui mais j'ai pas eu l'occasion d'aller
le voir
mais bon j'ai su quand même qu'il y
avait eu beaucoup de demandes toussaint
est donc une très belle performance
on l'a vu dans le reportage beaucoup de
sportifs des urinoirs et cherche à se
dépasser pendant cet événement 2
oui mais tout à fait tout à fait c est
le cas un peu des pompiers c'est une
telle qu'en aussi de nous a mis des
lions ce qu'ils avaient fait un pâté
l'année dernière de 67 m et cette année
il leur a mangé de cinq mètres de plus
le lion sur ce club et tout était vendu
je crois enfin autour de 14 heures alors
un petit mot sur la recherche où on est
on est ce qu il ya encore sur des
programmes un cherché en avance je vais
pas rentrer dans les détails de sa bande
ça mais y encore beaucoup
malheureusement beaucoup à faire pour
pour diverses recherches au niveau
national
on a juste cette année je le précise
qu'il ya eu des avancées notamment sur
la régénération de la rétine ou encore
un test sur une thérapie pour la
myopathie myotubulaire ça c'est mieux
tubulaire pardon cd des avancées qui a
eu qui a eu récemment important de le
rappeler aussi il ya bien sûr ce
week-end de mobilisation chaque année
mais on peut donner toute l'année vous
pouvez donner de toute l'année
oui si oui tout à fait mais dans le 36
37 marche jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
on appelle bien sûr ou dans 36 30e pour
faire augmenter le cancer
une fois que le week end et passez vous
en tant qu'ordinateur quel va être votre
rôle là dans la semaine qui vient
et c'est maintenant et bien récolter
tout ce qui a été collecté sur les
diverses manifestations
donc c'est un travail on va dire du mois
de décembre et du mois de janvier
donc ça se poursuivre sur les prochains
mois tout à fait on a déjà commencé
aujourd'hui et c'est un vin continuez
donc à rentrer parce que des grosses
manifestations comme montini bon c'est
très bien que c'est pas possible a
ramené le lendemain ben il ya toujours
un ramassés au niveau de diverses
associations
mais bon cette année on est bien parti
pour espère en faire une bonne remontée
déjà avant noël on suivra tout ça dans
la conclusion les bilans qui seront a
mené pendant ces prochaines semaines
merci à daniel basons d'avoir été avec
nous c'est coordinateur de l'afm
téléthon sur le secteur s des civils et
je rappelle que vous pouvez toujours
faire un don à la fm sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
je me tourne vers vous à présent marty
millage rappel vous êtes membre du
collectif migrants à versailles vous
mettez en place plusieurs actions pour
ces migrants va voir ça dans dans un
instant déjà un petit état des lieux
parlons de la question des migrants à
versailles ces premiers groupes sont
arrivés fin 2015
sur versailles au début c'était c'était
des couples et puis après en mars
c'était des jeunes hommes qui vous avez
entièrement raison elle en 2015 sur sont
les églises catholiques qui se sont
mobilisés pour accueillir des syriens
donc il ya plusieurs familles choix qui
en a entre huit et dix familles qui sont
accueillis dans les différentes
paroisses mais nous le collectif citoyen
on s'en occupe pas ça c'est vraiment
dans les paroisses est alors allée
migrants les jeunes gens qui ont entre
21 et 30 32 33 ans
ça ce sont des gens de calais beaucoup
venaient de calais et on était donc sont
arrivés ici après le démantèlement de la
retrait de la jungle de calais ce qu'on
a appelé la jungle de calais il y en a
200 qui sont arrivés à temps en
septembre 2000 2016 et ils ont été
d'abord il s'investit y en a certains
une centaine qui est resté jusqu'à
janvier 2010 est à l'inria qui avait mis
les locaux à disposition
starhawk tambour exactement et les
autres sont mortes mais donc là où il ya
les militaires prennent en bassin 19h
seul à versailles
et donc voilà c'est un petit versailles
vous savez où yahoo après la presle et
en bassin des suisses ils sont 120
environ se faire héberger ce sont
exactement ils sont 120
il ya deux deux immeubles 1 qui
appartient à l'armée et l'autre qui est
l'ancienne auberge de jeunesse vers sa
jeunesse
oui a donc ils sont ensemble enfin bon
il ya des passerelles et en termes de
capacité il est rempli incomplet complet
au complet maintenant c'est donc c'est
une question on l'a vu la semaine
dernière on vous avait interrogé lors
d'une fête de la fraternité de la vie
organisée
le gros problème c'est le logement c'est
un gros problème ces logements
il paraît qu'il y en a trois mille qui
dorment dehors à paris à versailles en a
quelques-uns nous on a cueilli un couple
de guinéens qu'on a rempli avec est
reparti à paris espérant avoir un
logement
le 115 ne répond pas il est surbooké on
n'a pas de logement
c'est un jeune couple guinéens de l eau
mais l'homme est musulman l'as
saint-etienne ils ont été rejetés par
leur famille exactement ils ont laissé
leurs enfants dans la famille del à
conakry qui a quatre ans et ils sont
arrivés ici est complètement démuni sans
argent sans rien donner sans rien ils
parlent français heureusement je crois
que vous hébergez vous vous même un
jeune pakistanais
alors moi j'ai berges jeunes pakistanais
depuis le 6 décembre qui a été alors
c'est un peu compliqué moi je fais
partie de welcome 78 où elle comme 78,7
une association de qui est tenu a été
créée par des jésuites et on accueille
des migrants pendant un mois entre
quatre et cinq semaines et après ils
changent de semaine
c'est une manière de découvrir la france
à travers différentes familles est
différent oui différentes familles les
vieux des jeunes des familles les
pressions sur le parcours vous êtes
ancien pasteur je vais lui le don de soi
le led à son prochain cd des notions qui
vous parle c'est des choses
oui je sais pas si c'est parce que ces
pasteurs bc oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
que ça nous tient à coeur l'accueil
c'est quelque chose de fondamental alors
le jeune pakistanais et chez moi parce
qu'il était à la rue d'accord et à
partir du 19
il est devenu voilà je ne peux plus le
garder à partir du 19 décembre
je cherche désespérément un accueil mais
on sait impossible impossible
il nous faudrait des appartements il
nous faudrait des locaux il nous
faudrait les bénévoles aussi écouter on
a énormément de bénévoles alors vraiment
sur la région peut pas se plaindre pour
cette fête de la fraternité
on envoie 130 invitation et on a des
réponses mais formidable
là la dernière fête à laquelle vous
étiez
on a eu cinq ans ces bénévoles y en
avait certains qui avaient même pas
debout et d'ailleurs les images
donc vous avez dit mobilisation au
niveau des bénévoles on l'a compris un
gros problème au niveau du logement et
vous avez tous partout pas seulement
chez nous vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
se sentent trempe aurait fait centres
temporaires pardon qui a été ouvert à
rocquencourt si on se remémore il y
avait eu beaucoup de levée de boucliers
à l'époque des élus des habitants aussi
vous avez un son que la question des
migrants ont fait encore peur
aujourd'hui est-ce que je peux être
méchante
ils sont quand même parquet chinois dont
qui sont partis de rien il y avait eu
des grosses manifestations au concours
mais il y avait eu aussi des grosses
manifestations pour l'accueil
si vous voulez ça va vraiment de pairs
d'accor faut il faut citer les deux fait
il faut citer les deux
la manifestation contre suscite
immédiatement
1 comment dire un bond de quelque chose
un effort et on a eu fort des anneaux
vraiment un effort formidable de
d'hommes de femmes jeunes et moins
jeunes qui sont tout de suite mobilisé
pour faire dire pas sauvage d'or un mot
sur les actions il nous reste une minute
déjà dans cet entretien du coup on a
parlé de cette fête de la fraternité il
y aussi des petits déjeuners sont servis
dans les films de toujours les
affections très important le lundi matin
donc ce matin à partir de 7 heures
jusqu'à 8h à peu près c'est ce que les
portes ouvrent avec des gens qui sont là
aussi pour parler avec les ceux qui font
la queue qui sont là depuis 4 heures du
matin voire femmes 4 heures du matin
aujourd'hui parce qu'il pleuvait mais il
y en a qui viennent déjà à 21h et qui
dorment sur des cartons et sur des
couvertures de survie et maintenant
depuis la semaine dernière il y en a un
deuxième petit déjeuner c'est le jeudi
matin 7 heures du matin il faut que vous
sachiez qu'il y a quand même entre 80 et
150 migrants hommes femmes jeunes et
moins jeunes tous les matins le lundi et
le jeudi
merci martin il a neigé les imprimés
membres du collectif migrants à
versailles merci et merci également à
daniel basons d'avoir été avec nous et
merci à vous deux filles aussi politique
une victoire dès le premier tour et sans
contestation possible laurent wauquiez a
été élu hier président du parti les
républicains il récolte 75% déçu
rage exprimé par les militants un succès
attendu et qui place l'ancien ministre
dans l'obligation de rassembler son camp
en mauvaise posture depuis l'élection
présidentielle et donc la nomination au
poste président d' emmanuel macron c'est
en tout cas ce qu'espère sophie primas
sénatrice des yvelines et secrétaire
départemental des républicains
interrogés par nicolas kirillovitch le
résultat était attendu et maintenant je
crois quoi on a tous envie qu'il se
passe quelque chose on s'appelle tout le
monde au rassemblement où ça il ya
beaucoup de gens qui parlent du
rassemblement qui n'ont pas un seul
échantillon sur eux comme aurait dit
coluche
donc maintenant je crois qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui a été élu il faut que dans
son comportement il appelle et donne des
signes du rassemblement et puis il faut
que les autres aussi et envie de
construire ait envie d'être rassemblés
c'est l'enjeu des trois prochains mois à
la fois dans comportement dans les
paroles dans les actes sans rémy les
chevreuse ne sera pas la première
commune francilienne en marche la liste
sans étiquette lit la conduite par
dominique bavoil a gagné hier l élection
municipale partielle
elle emporte de 22 voix d'avancé sur la
candidature lrm de dominique dufrasne
l'autre liste sans étiquette conduite
par jean-louis binic
elle arrive troisième de ce second tour
est dominique bavoil devrait donc être
désigné nouveau maire de saint rémy les
chevreuse alors d'un conseil municipal
extraordinaire
au programme vent de vendredi prochain
c'est l'une des championnes de la
croissance en france l'entreprise art ms
spécialisé dans les produits de haute
technologie pour la défense diversifie
son activité basée à saint quentin en
yvelines elle vient de lancer une
nouvelle campagne de commercialisation
pour un laser un laser effaroucheurs
d'oiseaux un produit qui répond à un
enjeu de sécurité pour les arts et les
aéroports
les précisions de nicolas kirillovitch
lors coût est estimé tous les ans à près
de 1 milliard et demi d'euros pour
l'aviation civile et peuvent être à
l'origine d'accidents mortels les
impacts entre les oiseaux et les avions
sur les pistes d'aéroport pourrait
bientôt presque disparaître et ce grâce
à un effaroucheur laser une technologie
développée à montigny le bretonneux par
l'entreprise à terme est ce comparable à
un prédateur à la lune
art verte et qui a pour but d'effrayer
les oiseaux aux abords des pistes les
systèmes sont actuellement sonore elle
il peut y avoir des rapaces mais le
rapace crée lui aussi lisant ce
potentiel est aujourd'hui le laser est
le seul système qui ne soit pas sonore
qui respecte l'environnement puisqu'il
ya pas de déchets et craint par les
oiseaux
le laser effaroucheurs équipe
actuellement plus d'une vingtaine
d'aéroports dans le monde et permet
selon des premières études de réduire
les collisions de 40% sans risque pour
la santé des animaux pour internet
entreprises spécialisées dans la défense
depuis 28 ans le développement de cette
technologie s'est concrétisé il ya
quelques années après le rachat d'une
société en difficultés financières c'est
un produit qui apporte une
diversification de aussi bien
technologique que le clientèle parce que
nous les aéroports c'est pas notre
vocation de vente du matériel à des
aéroports donc je produis nos amène des
clients nouveaux et une diversification
importante pour l'entreprise
le burkina faso devrait être le prochain
client de les farouches heures laser en
il y a quelques mois le journal les
échos classé à terme s parmi les 500
entreprises les plus dynamiques de
france
elle aussi est une référence sur le
territoire l'estac à montigny le
bretonneux accueillait une conférence
conférence annuelle du club climat
énergie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
thème cette année des éco quartier à la
ville intelligente
plusieurs partenaires comme le ministère
de la transition écologique et solidaire
où la commission de régulation de
l'énergie sont venus proposer leurs
projets leurs stratégies objectif
favoriser un développement énergétiques
performants tout en étant sobre pour vos
propos recueillis par aurélien 11 ce
thème c'est pour un regarder tous
ensemble comment en étant connecté on
peut régler un certain nombre de
problèmes de transport
un problème de d'énergie c'est à nous
d'essayer de trouver des solutions
notamment pour créer des éco quartiers
de demain
et puis aussi recyclé
ce qui peut l'être le projet est évoqué
pour la première fois en 1993 14 ans
plus tard c'est officiel maurepas aura
bien son cinéma un multiplex de huit
salles sortira de terre d'ici 2019
dans le village des loisirs la ville le
groupe propriétaire des terrains et le
futur exploitant se sont réunis mercredi
dernier pour signer le début des travaux
miquel et nuit droit et patrick jacques
de dixmude étaient sur place tous les
voyants sont enfin ouverts après plus de
neuf ans de discussions et nos recours
la ville de maurepas va accueillir un
multiplexe en 2019 en face du village
des loisirs
la signature officielle entre les
exploitants et effectué ce jeudi 7
décembre
un soulagement pour la mairie c'est un
projet de cinéma qui est très attendu
très attendu par les commerçants
moi qui vais les voir régulièrement
parce qu'ils sont en attente de ce
cinéma pour leur permettre à eux-mêmes
de se diversifier de s'agrandir ou même
d'investir et de créer de nouveaux
emplois
donc je suis vraiment totalement
satisfait ça va voilà dynamiser la ville
de maurepas le secteur et fait rayonner
notre belle ville au delà même de
maurepas le cinéma proposera notamment
des blockbusters américains et des
grands films français il sera équipé de
huit salles et plus de 1700 fauteuil
coût total de l'opération 13 millions
d'euros là comment on veut mettre toutes
les dernières technologies
le numérique bien sûr leçon atmos et
projecteur laser est comme il est éco
responsable et coûte un petit peu plus
cher mais en gros faut savoir
aujourd'hui à multiplex sur un
multiplexe
c'est un million d'euros la salle layana
8 savait pas 8 millions parce que
justement on veut faire quelque chose
d'un peu différent
les premiers coups de pioche seront
donnés au mois d'avril prochain les
exploiteurs espère attirer entre 450
mille cinq cent mille spectateurs
parents ont conclu ce journal sur le
paris versailles non pas en course à
pied mais un vélocipède c'est et hier
dimanche 21 participants ont pris le
départ de la capitale sur l'ancêtre du
vélo dans des conditions climatiques et
difficile
un hommage la première course cycliste
de l'histoire c'était en 1867 reportage
sur la ligne de départ de nicolas
d'andré c'était le 8 décembre 1867 il ya
maintenant 150 ans l'arrivée à
versailles de la première course
cycliste
les grosses roues en bois des costumes
d'époque une constitution de ce paris
versailles avec 2
véritable vélocipède l'ancêtre de la
petite reine développé par la famille
olivier est rousse on part exactement
dans laxe donc il faut faire extrêmement
attention les pédales sont complètement
fixé à la roue avant c'est pas évident
pour freiner il faut pas se laisser
emballer
donc c'est pas évident de faire du
vélocipède loin de la journaliste
sportif passionné de cyclisme gérard
holtz a participé à cette course
un véritable cadeau d'anniversaire lui
qui fêtait ses 71 ans ce vendredi 8
décembre
c'est un peu comme un moto ouais ouais
en fait c'est comme la main presque de
l'enduro du motocross
ouais super souple sur les bras j'ai il
a fallu un petit 1 g/km pour que je
comprenne waratahs super trash - tenue
on se propulse donc en appuyant sur les
pédales à l'avant ici est le problème
regardez le problème est là pour la
précision de la conduite
la difficulté c'est ça faut pas mettre
la roue dans les trous on tourne guidon
comme ça pour tirer sur la corde et le
patin ici fresnes et bloquent la roue
spécialiste de l'histoire du vélocipède
le japonais kenzo kobayashi s'est
passionné de cyclisme il a fait le tour
du japon en bicyclette à 19 ans comme
c'est la première cause devait rester
dans le monde
donc j'ai senti vraiment offert
l'histoire mais au physique avec les
conditions climatiques compliquées les
cyclistes ont mis près de quatre heures
trente pour boucler les 17 km entre
paris et versailles soit trois heures de
plus que les trois premiers en 1867
selon les récits historiques
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal édition
à revoir sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]